[Music]
on this monday night a troubling
prognosis from toronto's top doctor
we are approaching a new pandemic the
rise of more contagious variants
as some provinces relax restrictions
plus
anxiety over education i
don't want to be homeschooling the
teenager emerging
from a 10-month coma i don't know how
joseph will ever
understand how his family is trying to
explain the pandemic
to him
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with promising signs
easing restrictions and deep concern
about what could be around the corner
covid19 cases case counts are down in
many parts of this country
health officials credit the diligence of
canadians abiding by public health
guidelines
for bending the curve downward the seven
day average of new cases has dropped by
more than half
over the past month but there is a good
chance
it won't stay that way every day more
cases of the highly transmissible
variants are detected in canada
in toronto a case of the variant that
first emerged in brazil has been
confirmed
the city's top doctor has this warning
we are in a transition from one pandemic
to another a transition
to a new pandemic we are in a position
of great uncertainty with respect to
variance
but what we know is alarming
decisions to reopen do not come with
guarantees
except that cases of covid19 will rise
when we interact again more frequently
the variants are easier to catch and
easier to spread and there is
uncertainty about the effectiveness
of vaccines against them south africa
has suspended a plan to use the oxford
astrazeneca vaccine on frontline
healthcare workers there
after a clinical trial suggested it's
not effective against the south african
variant
in the midst of all this uncertainty
some provinces
are easing restrictions ross lord has
our top story tonight
the ontario government suggests it's
striking the right balance between
public health
and the economy we will be able to
protect our people
our frontline heroes our communities and
our businesses
the premier says stay-at-home
restrictions will continue for most of
the province
but in the coming weeks ontario will
cautiously transition regions to
gradually reopening
based on infection rates on monday
schools reopened for students in 13
public health units
including windsor and hamilton elsewhere
nova scotia is allowing more people into
retail
businesses and fitness centers
increasing limits
from 50 percent to 75 percent full
quebec is expanding businesses that can
open to include non-essentials like hair
salons
and alberta has decided to allow
in-person restaurant dining
along with limited school and team
sports
a welcomed taste of normalcy it feels
different like obviously it's not very
busy
so it's kind of a different atmosphere
but it's also like comforting to be back
the small reward for recent success
against covert 19.
so i think the fact that we've been
seeing declining case counts
overall have really been a sign that
people have been
taking things more seriously manitoba
says it's considering slowly easing
restrictions later this week
while bc is extending restrictions
indefinitely
heeding the advice of canada's chief
public health officer
teresa tam is repeating that it's
crucial strong measures are kept in
place
in order to maintain a steady downward
trend
researchers warn some provinces that go
easy are inviting
more trouble from highly contagious
variants because measures like contact
tracing are still lacking
strikes me that this rush to open many
things at once is not the most
strategic endeavor he says looser rules
mean a third wave of covet cases in the
spring
becomes more likely ross lord global
news
newfoundland and labrador reported a
jump in cases today the largest single
day increase since april of 2020
11 new cases of covid19 were confirmed
are pushing the total number of active
cases to 27.
health authorities have suspended all
group recreational and arts activities
in the st
john's area there are also new
visitation restrictions on long-term
care homes
to reduce the risk to the elderly
restrictions are being eased in quebec
even though cases of the variants have
been detected there and politicians and
public health officials acknowledge
their spread could
quickly change the game amanda gellawiki
reports
finally we have our life back
yes this montreal woman celebrates the
reopening of quebec's stores
with a shopping trip for sure kovit is
here
but we're alive happy
smiling and yes there's a life at the
end of the tunnel
after being closed for six weeks
non-essential businesses reopened today
it's the first step in a gradual
loosening of restrictions
reopening is key it's going to save
businesses
it's we don't expect it to be a problem
in terms of
health but many in quebec worry about
the impact on public health
i would have said that we should have
kept non-essential businesses closed for
longer
quebec coving cases spiked over the
holidays with over three thousand in one
day
hospitals warned they were on the brink
of catastrophe
since adopting an 8 pm curfew last month
cases now
hover around a thousand a day the
premier admits reopening is a delicate
balancing act
i think it's calculated risk
and it's a balance also taking into
consideration
mental health but some argue cases are
still
too high it's like we have our fingers
around the neck
of this uh of this pandemic and this is
where
instead of loosening our grip we should
be tightening our grip
experts worry with new more contagious
covet variants already in canada
loosening restrictions could backfire
because if you stay home
you can't catch the virus from somebody
and you can't pass the virus to someone
over the weekend quebec surpassed ten
thousand cova deaths the highest in
canada
it's a number that looms large in a
province opening up
while the virus is still spreading
amanda jellowicky
global news montreal
the rollout of vaccines in canada is
still lagging this week just over
70 000 doses of the pfizer biotech
vaccine are expected
far short of the 366 000 a week that
were planned
and canada will receive no doses of the
moderna vaccine
the company delivers its vaccine once
every three weeks
the next scheduled shipment isn't until
the week of february 22nd
the country that has the highest
vaccination rate in the world
still has rising case numbers in israel
more than a third of people have now
received at least one dose and a
national lockdown is in place
but cobit cases are still rising in part
because
of the fast spreading variants it is now
confirmed the variant first identified
in the uk
has been detected in nine cases of an
outbreak at a toronto
meat plant belmont meats voluntarily
closed over a week ago as cases
began to spread toronto public health
has confirmed 95 cases connected
to that outbreak recent exposures of the
uk variant at schools in alberta and bc
do not appear to be spreading at this
point students at five schools in those
provinces have attended classes while
infectious with the more highly
transmissible virus
as heather urex west reports early data
is giving reason
for cautious optimism sarah park has
four kids they're all back in school
right now and she hopes to keep it that
way
i don't want to be homeschooling my kids
don't want to be home
but park admits the new variants worry
her her oldest
has already been sent home to isolate
twice and she worries that could start
to happen more frequently
if variants take hold in the community
the concern
is that it is a more highly
transmissible strain which means it can
spread from person to person more
readily than the
other strains of copenhagen that we've
seen
that's what happened in this small dutch
village near rotterdam last november
an outbreak at an elementary school led
to more than 120 cases
more than a third had the uk variant
after testing everyone in the village
the local public health agency found the
new variant was spreading more easily
but among children the difference was
small
it turned out the results were
reassuring there was somewhat more
spreads but the
differences were minimal canada has had
less experience with these variants but
early data on some of the country's
first school exposures
has been reassuring too after a person
attended class at garibaldi school in
maple ridge bc while infectious with the
uk variant
80 people were tested and every test
came back
negative the results of the testing that
we did out of caution
to ensure that we were picking up any
transmission showed us that the safety
plans that were in place
in that school worked it's a positive
sign it's too soon to be confident about
anything
if anything dr kellner says the new
variants leave schools with a smaller
margin for error when it comes to things
like proper mask wearing
and physical distancing it's a time to
be reminded that
this is important and it does make a
difference it's advice sarah park
is taking to heart i know masks aren't
cool and i know as teenagers no one
wants to wear them
but if it means the difference between
in person school or more time learning
at home
she hopes the extra vigilance will pay
off heather urex west global
news calgary the energy sector is
digging its way out of the coveted
doldrums the price of the global
benchmark brent crude surged by more
than two percent today climbing
to above sixty dollars a barrel for the
first time in over
a year the boost is credited to a cut in
oil production and optimism
about recovery from the pandemic and
bitcoin
surged to a record high today after
being energized by electric car maker
tesla
the company revealed it has stockpiled
more than 1.5 billion dollars u.s in the
cryptocurrency
tesla says it will also start accepting
it as a form of payment
that pushed a single bitcoin to more
than 43 000
u.s today the price of the
cryptocurrency has risen by
50 percent this year two investigations
are now underway into allegations of
inappropriate behavior
involving the former chief of the
defense staff general jonathan vance
canada's former top soldier allegedly
had an ongoing relationship with a woman
he significantly outranked
and made a sexual comment to a second
much younger soldier
let's bring in mike locateur in ottawa
now mike an investigation into such a
high ranking general is highly unusual
how could this case proceed well donna
when the structure of discipline inside
the military was first established it's
unlikely
they ever thought the country's top
soldier could potentially
face a court-martial in a general court
martial system the accused is judged by
a panel chaired by a senior officer
the senior member of that panel must be
equal to or higher in rank than the
accused
problem is in the canadian military
system the chief of the defense staff
is the top soldier general vance will be
tried if he is charged under the code of
service discipline and tribe by court
martial
he will be tried as a general there is
only
one other person who holds that rank
and that's the chief of the defense
staff and if the chief of the defense
staff is the referral authority
he cannot be the senior member of the
panel
exclusive reporting by global news last
week revealed
general jonathan vance allegedly had an
ongoing relationship with a woman
he significantly outranked including
while she was under his direct command
and
that he allegedly made a sexual advance
over email to another woman
who was a young corporal the canadian
forces national investigation services
has opened an investigation
and interviewed one of the women
allegedly involved
general vance has denied all allegations
that he ever
acted inappropriately towards any female
subordinates
sources told global news the military
ombudsman raised concerns with the
defense minister in 2018
about alleged sexual misconduct by
general vance
with women in the forces defense
minister harjit sajin insists
any information about allegations was
passed along to the appropriate
authorities
why didn't he act and if his answer is
as it appears to be well i told someone
else to act
i think the ball still passes back to
him when they didn't
and that's exactly why they're holding
an emergency meeting of the
parliamentary committee on national
defense
on tuesday donna
okay mike look at her in ottawa thanks
what a difference
ten months makes coming up the young man
emerging from a coma
to a radically changed world
there's a remarkable story from england
tonight about a teenager who has no
memory of the pandemic
he's been in a coma for 10 months now he
is beginning to recover from it and his
family is trying to explain how the
world has changed
redmond shannon has his story when
joseph flavel was hit by a car on march
first
he suffered a severe traumatic brain
injury
his aunt says doctors weren't sure if
the 18 year old
would survive joseph was clearly in a
lot of pain
all his muscles were contracted um
he had a tracheoscopy that was
dislodged which led to aspiration
pneumonia
lying in a coma flaval's life was on
pause
weeks later much of the planet also shut
down for the global pandemic
even though joe was unaware he wasn't
unaffected
he got covered on top of everything else
he's since had it again
unfortunately but at that time we were
very concerned
last may the sports mad teen should have
been at buckingham palace
receiving a gold duke of edinburgh award
which honors
youth achievement for months he remained
in a coma
until just before new year's a miracle
he began waking up joseph can can hear
us we know he can hear us because he
responds to small commands
i mean i don't know where um and how we
can explain to joseph
the world that he's woken up into
perhaps the hardest thing to explain is
why his family can't be
at his bedside his facetime smiles
bring them to tears you know sharon
who's joseph's mum will
say to joseph i really want to be with
you darling i'm sorry i want to come and
hold your hand
don't be scared because obviously for
joseph he's woken up
not and he hasn't got any of his loved
ones around him joe
now aged 19 faces a long road of
rehabilitation
his family is just thankful he's finally
starting
that journey redmond shannon global news
london
ahead the new federal green party leader
and her new political strategy
there has been no federal election call
in canada yet but it could be coming in
the months ahead and all parties are
preparing
it will be the first election for the
green party's new leader annemie paul
she has been focusing on policy
announcements including the campaign for
a universal basic income a shift in
focus for the greens
our chief political correspondent david
aiken joins me david you
also discovered something that could
distract from election preparations
donna last fall the party's executive
director quit
after some party members raised concerns
about his work for a previous employer
but
some other party members thought those
concerns were unfair
and they thought the party handled the
case poorly and now
those party members want the party
leadership to address this issue
and so they have sent a letter to the
party's federal council
copy this letter was obtained by global
news and they explained
why a pattern of poor governance has
taken hold at the green party
qualified effective and innovative
professionals within our party
are often pushed away we as a party must
do better
the letter was signed by the party's
former interim leader joanne roberts a
former national campaign director
jonathan dickey and others
including a past president and a past
party president
current party leader anime paul took
over weeks after the controversial
personnel decision was made
it's not having an impact on our
electoral preparedness
paul's bigger challenge is to convince
canadians her party is about
more than just climate change polls show
that while climate change
was a top of mind issue for most voters
in 2019
the pandemic has changed that and voters
now are much more concerned about their
own health
and their own ability to pay the bills
as a result
expect paul and the greens to have a
different emphasis in 2021
than the greens did in 2019. there is no
climate justice without social justice
as well
and so during this pandemic our focus
has been
while never forgetting the climate of
course has been on ensuring that people
don't fall through the cracks
the green party will also have a new
tactical focus this spring
aiming squarely at the ndp trying to
turn the two dozen
orange seats in the house of commons
into two dozen
green seats donna okay david aiken in
ottawa thanks
new team no problem up next tom brady
continues his super bowl
dominance
edmonton's still nameless cfl team now
has a short list of seven names to
replace the old one
the edmonton eskimos it is asking fans
to
rank the names in a second and final
survey the shortlist is
the edmonton elk the evergreens the
evergolds
eclipse elkhounds eagles
and elements in the nfl the kansas city
chiefs have stopped short of changing
their name despite intense pressure and
on the field at the super bowl yesterday
the team was no match for tampa bay and
quarterback tom brady the 43 year old
won his seventh
super bowl as eric sorenson reports it
is getting harder for his critics to
deny
his greatness as a player
it just didn't seem possible it's a
physically brutal sport
and he's 43. he should be limping to the
hall of fame
instead tom brady has broken seemingly
unbreakable records
that were set by tom brady super bowl 55
will be remembered as the pandemic bowl
with fewer fans
but it was also supposed to represent a
changing of the guard
young patrick mahomes and the kansas
city chiefs were favored
but in the end were no match for brady
and the buccaneers
some of the greatest quarterbacks united
nameth montana
quietly wound down their careers in
unfamiliar uniforms
it seemed brady was doing the same his
legacy forever a patriot
as a buccaneer hardly recognizable but
instead of fading away
brady won his seventh super bowl one of
the great achievements in sports history
you're looking at the greatest right
there well i think they're all special
there were no grand pronouncements from
brady you want to get this far you got
to get the job done and we did it
he's careful for all his accomplishments
brady has been one of the most
polarizing athletes in pro sports
he and his old team were accused in two
cheating scandals
for spying on another team and for
deflating footballs
brady was also criticized for not taking
a strong public stand when colin
kaepernick
raised awareness of racial injustice and
was apparently blackballed by the nfl
when your teammates are taking a knee
how can you not see color use
your privilege to amplify
social justice that's what he's failed
to do
it's all added up to a sharp divide in
public perception of the man
i hate tom brady so much and he knows it
reading a series of mean tweets about
himself last week
hi i'm tom brady and i'm a crybaby hope
everyone has a great monday
except for tom brady but as a player
even some skeptics have been won over
i have finally acquiesced what he has
done over his career his flat out
unparalleled and phenomenal i think we
knew this was going to happen tonight
didn't we
tom brady is controversial but is he
also the greatest player of all time
it's complicated eric sorensen global
news toronto
and that is global national for this
monday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada
is the emira oval in halifax there are
beautiful spots all over this country
please email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye